- Oh, my God, he will not
let it go. (man laughs)
You can tell he is Latin,
because Latin people
are tenacious as (beep)
My name is Nick Barili
and I'm traveling the
country to sit down
with some of the
biggest Latinx artists
in places that have
meaning to them,
and help tell their stories.
We'll talk about their
journeys and careers
and explore issues of
identity, culture,
discrimination,
and representation.
This is Seen.
(upbeat music)
- Good morning, welcome to my hotel room.
I am in New York city,
flew across the country from LA.
We are on our way to meet John Leguizamo.
Not only is he having a huge
impact on multiple platforms,
but he also touched my
life in a personal way.
When I got to see his one
man show as a teenager,
and really felt seen for the first time.
Also we're gonna give the man his flowers.
It's been three decades that
he's been doing it on Broadway,
on film and TV, and now
writing a comic book.
So the man does it all
and he does it with humor.
And I'm just really excited
about what we're gonna get to do today.
So let's go.
(upbeat music)
- You're late.
- Hello.
Nick.
- What's up it's so good to meet you-
- How are you doing,
what took you so long?
- I'm sorry, New York traffic.
- Yeah New York traffic sucks.
(upbeat music)
We're going downstairs to my man cave,
where the craziness happens.
(upbeat music)
- It's a beautiful home you have.
- Oh, thank you.
But you say it to everybody,
you meet though. (upbeat music)
- Oh wow.
I feel like I'm in a
college professor's office
about to get in trouble.
(man laughs)
- Now Nick called you into the office
because we've heard rumors about you.
- They're all true.
- Please share them I'm
ready to take down notes.
(man laughs)
I wanna learn from you.
So when you did that
and then what'd you do?
- I wanna take it back before
we even start the interview.
- Sure.
- Because you actually
played a key role in my life.
- How's that?
- When I was a senior in
high school in Berkeley,
my girlfriend at the time was like,
I wanna go see this show that's
coming to Zellerbach hall.
And I was like, I can't
afford Zellerbach Hall.
I tell her oh, it is expensive.
She was like, "Oh, if we're the ushers,
we'll get into the show
for free." (man laughs)
I was like, all right-
- She has a whole system, yeah.
- I was like all right let's go.
And it was "Freak.'
I didn't really know
what I was getting into,
but I remember sitting down
and just from the start of your show,
and this is me as a senior in high school
was the first time that
I really felt seen.
It was the first time that I was like,
wow, there's somebody here
who's got one foot in hip hop,
one foot in Latin culture.
Who's going through all
these different things
with their parents, with immigration.
Cause I'm a first-generation immigrant.
It was really the first
time where I saw myself
on stage, on TV, on something
and really felt like,
okay, I'm not going through this alone.
And that was the first
time that I was like,
oh, maybe I can do something in media.
Maybe I could do something
to represent the journey
that I'm going through and all the people
that are going through the
things that I'm going through.
- Well, that's incredible,
'cause that's what I
wanted to do with my work.
I wanted to reach people who are like me,
kids that were like me,
that felt unseen, unwanted,
that you didn't matter,
you didn't count,
cause you have to fight that every day.
That sense of I can't do this,
this place is not geared for me.
So, you know I wanted to shake
that up and go, yes you can.
Every one of us can.
- I always like to kind
of start interviews
by setting the tone,
the way that the intro
sequence in the movie was.
So if we take it back to Jackson Heights
to your childhood home,
that intro sequence like
pans into childhood home,
what are we seeing? What
are we hearing? (man laughs)
What are we smelling?
- Yeah.
So you're going through Jackson Heights
and you're coming down
(man whistling)
into the planet and then
you see a subway pass by.
And when the subway clears,
you keep going through
and there's our apartment
on the fourth floor 4A of on Deadman
Street. And it was a culdesac
right next to the subway.
So I would watch a lot of TV
and maybe this is why I
learned partly how to write
was because that'd be watching
like Dan August or something.
When they go, "We just got the killer,"
and the train would come up chu chu chu
and you would see this
(man laughs)
and that's who the murderer was.
And I was like, what?
So I used to have to try
to piece it all together
in my head.
And then you would see
my mom cooking I mean,
who knows pig's feet.
garbonzos
you know, rice.
- What are the sounds that were emanating
from the streets at that time?
- Yeah sounds were kids
playing, yelling, music,
music at the time was
always Salsa or some RNB.
And then Up-rock. Dancing was huge
at all the community centers afterschool.
And then when hip hop came, you know,
all my friends who were like
incredible break-dancers,
which I couldn't.
I'd go home and you know,
you practice in your room
and your mom would go
(in Spanish)
what are you doing in there?
You breaking the walls?
You're just throwing yourself
around, trying to grab a move.
But all you're doing is as
bashing against the walls.
- Talk a little bit about
having that energy growing up,
I read that you actually got into acting
kind of by getting into trouble at school.
Can you take us back to that time?
- You know I was like a class cut up
kind of like a problematic child.
I was the poster child for trouble kid.
The school made me go to therapy
'cause they wouldn't let me
back unless I had therapy,
which I hated at the moment.
But then now, you know, it saved my life.
But one of my friends
Indio suggested like,
why don't we commandeer
the number seven train
and you get on the mic.
It was like an open mic.
He made up his own open
mic night on the subway.
So we kicked the conductor's booth open,
and then I grabbed the mic
and I started, you know,
(man laughs)
doing all my voices
(man mumbling)
I'll say boy I said, boy,
you're a chicken hog boy.
- Over the speaker for the whole?
- Yes.
- Wow.
- And I kept going and
going and singing songs
and whatever.
- How did you go from that to
actual having acting classes?
- Well, my math teacher,
Mr.Uzufa would tell me,
instead of, you know, Mr. Leguizamo
instead of wrecking the class,
they can make penicillin from moldy bread.
They can make something out of you.
Why don't you take your,
whatever it is that you're
doing become a comedian?
So it was like the first person that said,
oh wow I could maybe
do something with this.
And he was a mentor, you know?
Mr. Uzufa was a mentor.
You need like, when you
come from the neighborhoods
that we come from,
you need somebody outside of
you to tell you that you can,
that you're worthy.
So I needed that several times.
So yeah I found an acting school
Sylvia Leigh Showcase Theater.
And I went there and this
little old lady who looked,
sounded like Katharine Hepburn's was like,
"Oh, it's so good to have you.
Ah ah."
And then I, you know, I
say, what was that lady?
What you do?
She's like, "Oh, your accent is horrific,
we're going to have to do something.
You'll never work with that sound."
What's up lady?
Why not? And you know, so she gave me,
she sold me like hundreds of dollars worth
of like dialect classes.
So she was making a buck off my back,
but you know, that's why I
sound so incredible today.
So you can't tell where I'm from.
You thought I was from England,
didn't you? (man laughs)
Why are you laughing like that?
- 'Cause I heard the same thing.
Like I originally want to
be a sports broadcaster,
and people were like, you'll
never be a sports broadcaster,
you got a thick accent.
Like that's not, oh,
and you have, you know,
you slow down your speech and sometimes,
and they're like, you'll
never be a sport broadcaster.
- How crazy is that,
cause that's the sound that I wanna hear.
I'm like, where are the
Latinx sports casters?
I wanna hear those sounds.
- Yeah.
- I was talking to a
couple of friends recently,
we're doing a movie and there
were three Latin people in it,
which was like a miracle
because it's, I'm always the only one,
and they're the only ones.
This one actress had a much thicker accent
because she's younger, so she's
had less time to work on it.
But I go, I love your sound.
You know, I love Rosie Perez's sound.
I love Dascha Polanco's sound.
I love those the way
that the language moves,
the dip thongs is stretched
out and little bit of urban,
a little Latino in it is
such a beautiful sound.
- Yep.
Once you started to act,
did that feel like a way
to just work through some of that energy?
- I think it's a combination of things.
I mean, definitely in that acting class,
the teacher was brilliant actually.
And she gave me "Dino" this book,
it's about a teenager
who's having troubles
at home with his, hates his father
(man laughs)
and was arrested and is in therapy.
And it was like, oh wait,
check, check, check, check.
So when I did it, it was like an epiphany.
But that's when I realized,
oh my God, I can do this.
This is only thing I wanna do.
I don't wanna...
I don't care if I'm famous,
or successful, or rich,
I just wanna do this thing.
- I think there's a couple of
years before you get to NYU,
what are those years like?
And is that when you're working at KFC?
- KFC was paying for my acting classes.
Cause her diction
classes and diction tapes
were mad expensive.
So yeah I worked there for two years.
At the Times Square KFC, I saw things
that no young man should ever see.
- Walk me through that
period in your life.
I mean, you're working
at KFC, you're acting,
you're going to school.
- Yeah.
- Like what was that time like?
We see now we see all the awards,
we see this amazing office you have,
but it's like, I'm sure
there's somebody watching
who is probably in those shoes
when you were at that time,
figuring how am I gonna
make it out of this job?
And to start my career.
- I was failing in high school,
but I was doing the acting classes.
I was in therapy.
And then, you know, reality hit.
I was like, oh my God, I
gotta apply for colleges.
My grade point was terrible and
(in Spanish)
How do you say in Spanish,
I got my act together?
I got sharp and I was
like, I gotta fix myself.
I gotta fix my life.
- What inspired you to.
(in Spanish)
“To get your act together."
- Working at Kentucky Fried Chicken,
you know, I just saw what I'm not.
I did it all, I was cook, I was cashier,
I did the cater, I did it all.
I go, this is gonna be
the rest of my life.
I don't want that to be me.
I wanna have something.
And then I couldn't get into NYU at first.
I had to go to C.W. Post,
which actually ended up
being the most education
I ever got in my entire
life with those two years,
I spent at CW post.
And then I transferred to NYU
because that was the best acting program
that I thought existed in America.
Here I am in NYU, A student.
I had fixed my accent a lot by this point.
And all the white kids in my class
were going to five auditions a day.
I was going to one every
five months and I was like,
wait a minute, I'm working
as hard as they are,
I got better grades.
And then I realized, oh my God,
I don't have the same
opportunities as they have.
And I realized, I know I realized
that it wasn't an equal playing field.
You know, it just was never gonna be.
You're a disillusioned, you're
a young man and you realize,
oh my God, life is not fair.
Just because of how I look, how I sound,
my economic class that I come from,
it's just not a fair playing field,
no matter how talented you
are, it doesn't matter.
And, but I thought talent-
- [Interviewer] Was the equalizer.
- It was the great equalizer.
And so the audition that I
would go to every five months
was always for a drug
dealer, a murderer, a killer,
or somebody, your gardener or
somebody servicing your house.
And it was like, wait a minute,
I've worked this hard to be
playing those kinds of roles?
I started doing improv and other things
cause I was like this
working towards Hollywood,
which was really Holly-wouldn't
was not gonna be the place.
So I've start to find
other ways other avenues.
And I started finding
theater, Off-Broadway theater
and performance art,
and performance art was the
place that I found my freedom.
- Was that your way of
just showing Hollywood
your own worth through your own eyes,
not through their eyes?
- Yes, yes.
Writing became my way to,
for me as an artist to be my full self
and how I saw myself, not how Hollywood
or Network TV saw me.
Cause look right now, the
census came out, the 2020 Census
and said almost 20% of the population.
And then a couple of years ago,
we were only 3% of the faces
in front of the camera,
less than 1% of the stories,
less than 1% of the crew,
less than 1% of the executives.
That's cultural apartheid.
And the same thing goes for politics,
less than 1% of elected officials
and forget about publication,
Latin children are least seen
in children's picture books.
So right then there,
your self esteem as a child
is already being challenged.
Think about that,
marinate on that.
I'll be right back.
(man laughs)
Thank you for joining us in
my podcast with Nick and John.
- The people who might
not be of the culture
might not fully understand the
full impact of that, right?
Because that not only
affects our self-esteem,
it also affects how
people who don't interact
with us on a daily basis, see us.
- See us.
- Then they don't necessarily think
about our positive
contributions to this country.
- Right. So not only are we invisible,
but when we are seen it's
a negative portrayal.
- You said in an interview,
it was in 94, it was on PBS.
And you said that most of the roles
that you were up for were stereotypical
and were one dimensional,
and you were just asking
to have three dimensional characters
who could actually lead a movie
and not just be supporting.
- Right how do you create
a Latin star in America,
when the roles are one dimensional
and not worthy of awards?
The ugly question is why
aren't Latin people succeeding?
What's the ugly question?
Are we not smart enough?
Not talented enough?
Not good looking enough?
Not hardworking enough?
No, none of those
stereotypes and racist ideas.
Cause nobody tries
harder with less access.
A friend of mine, I won't say her name,
years ago when I was doing
Mambo Mouth sent out her resume.
Dark-skinned Latin woman sent
out her resume with a picture,
one with a Latin name, her real name,
and then one with a white-fied name.
The white-fied got callbacks,
the Latin one got nothing.
That's just-
- Just off a name.
- Just off a name exactly.
And that's just explains
the whole situation
right then and there.
- You made that statement in 94
where, you know, almost 30 years later,
do you feel like things have changed?
- Yes, yes.
Things have changed
incrementally unfortunately.
40 years I've been in this business
and I guess we went from
1% to maybe this year,
I think we're gonna be at four or 5%
in front of the camera,
I'm not sure what the numbers are behind.
I mean, things are improving.
I think COVID made us really
look at ourselves in America.
I think Black Lives Matter was
huge awakening for America,
a reboot for America to look at themselves
and see what's going on.
I think everybody's trying
to do the right thing
and hire many more people of color.
I mean, what I wanna see,
I want to see 20% of the
roles in front of the camera,
of the crew, of the
stories, of the executives.
We're 25% at the US box office.
- Yeah one in four.
- And we have 3% of the faces?
I'm not asking for extra
I just want what's due us.
I mean, I've seen the development process
through all my life at
every studio, New Line,
Universal, Fox Searchlight.
They work on scripts for years and years,
polishing them, making it better.
And half of those die
and then half of them
make it to the screen.
We need to be in that pipeline.
They need to be taking Latin scripts
and working them that hard,
so by the time they get to this point,
they're the best that can be.
- Yeah.
- But it just takes
somebody who looks like me
being an executive and
saying that story is worth it
cause I've been pitching
stories for 30 years,
Always thinking that my
writing was falling short
because they never got green-lit.
So I was like, damn I
thought it was a good script.
But then I'm winning awards
on Broadway and off-Broadway
Obie awards and Drama
Desk Awards for my writing
and a Tony, Tony
nominations and even Emmy's,
but never getting my movies done.
And you know, there was
always excuses were white,
Latin people don't wanna see Latin people.
I'm like, no,
then who do I wanna see
for Christmas at my house?
Some Norwegian family?
I wanna see Latin people
is what I wanna see.
Or they would tell me like
when Critical Thinking,
I directed, they would tell me,
"Latin people don't wanna
see feel good movies."
No, no we wanna see really
depressing suicidal flicks.
That's-
- That's an actual conversation?
- [John] Yeah actual thing.
- That's insane that that
would come out of someone.
- Was it, it's Hollywood wisdom.
There is an audience and a hunger,
I know that exists regardless
of what a studio head
or network says to me anymore.
I know Hamilton would have
never got made at a studio
or a network.
They would have been, "Oh I'm sorry, Lynn,
I'm sorry but wait a minute,
Burr's gonna be black and
Hamilton's gonna be Puerto Rican?
I'm so sorry, I didn't mean to laugh,
but I can assure they
didn't speak in hip hop
back in the 1700s the founding father."
It would have never gotten made, never.
But theater, there are no gatekeepers.
You just gotta raise that
money and get a good review,
and now you've got the biggest masterpiece
that Broadway has ever seen.
(upbeat music)
- I have a bunch more questions,
but how do you wanna space it between here
and the restaurant?
- Oh, he's hungry.
That's his segue.
(men laughs)
That's his subtle way
of saying I'm hungry.
(upbeat music)
'Cause your stomach was grumbling
I'm gonna take you to lunch.
- Yeah, is this one of
your favorites spots?
- One of my favorite spots,
the margarita's are killer.
(upbeat music)
Down here I mean, I used
to go to a lot of theater
and perform.
That's where you would ask
me about where did I perform?
It was, I did my
performance art at PS 122,
a converted school,
Gusto House, Dixon Place,
The Kitchen, Knitting Factory,
all these little spots like
he had like 20 people maybe,
(man laughs)
in the audience.
- Do you remember that first time
that you hit the stage
what that feeling was like?
- Oh my God, it was incredible.
I was doing a one-man piece.
It was a one-man show about Latin people
had written the Bible, as Jesus, and Mary
and all Latinos, you know,
loud and boisterous and fun.
And the crowd loved it.
And it was amazing.
It was my first full
length piece that I wrote
and performed by myself,
playing all the characters.
- Were you nervous or?
- Oh hell yeah.
If you're not nervous, then you're not,
then it's not really, you're
not really risking anything.
(upbeat music)
Here we are it's my spot right here.
You have your vax card?
- Yup.
- Hey, how you doing?
How's it going?
How are you?
(upbeat music)
How about a little mescal?
- I'm down, what are you drinking?
- A little Oaxaca express.
- [Waiter] Oaxaca express?
- Yeah.
(upbeat music)
Yeah.
Oh, here comes, Here's lunch.
(man laughs)
- Two Oaxaca express.
- Thank you.
Thank you brother.
- Appreciate it.
- It's a meal replacement here we go.
- Cheers.
- Cheers brother, heres to you.
- To you.
To all the doors you've opened.
- And the glass ceiling, that keeps...
I got scars in my head from
hitting that glass ceiling.
Luckily I'm hardheaded so
I don't really feel it.
- I feel like we have
to be in this industry
just to be able to make
it past all the no's.
- Yes.
- Talk about that a little bit.
Cause I feel like you hear so
many no's that like it's hard,
I don't care how hard your skin is.
- Yeah.
- At some point you start
to internalize that.
Like how do you maneuver
through the industry
and all the no's?
- It's interesting because
you know, the rule is,
you become a celebrity, you get
a certain amount of success,
you don't talk about your problems.
You don't talk about the difficulties.
You act like, oh it was a
magic carpet ride you know,
I feel like it's really important
to talk about all the problems
and all the difficulties,
especially if you're a person of color,
and especially if you're Latinx,
there's a lot of the people struggling
and we need to change things.
And Spike Lee showed me
cause he's one of the first
who spoke out against #Hollywoodsowhite.
Well, he was #Oscarsowhite,
but I wasn't sure
(man laughs)
if you're okay, so let's be real.
So he brought that out
and I was like, yeah,
I went right and started
re-tweeting him like crazy.
And then I had posted #Oscarsowhite,
but #Hollywoodsevenwhiter.
You know, there's colorism
within Latin culture
that we have to fix,
but there's colorism in Hollywood too.
I mean, I'd benefited
from being light-skinned,
and I stayed out of the
sun so I could work.
- [Nick] Wow.
- I definitely would not
go in the sun for years.
I was so pasty-
- That was a conscious thing?
- Oh yeah, so I could work.
And all the Latinos that made it so far,
a lot of them were all
light-skinned you know,
what happened to all the Afro-Latino
and the majority of indigenous Latinos,
they don't get a shot, you know?
So there's a lot of things we
got to deal with in Hollywood,
and we gotta fix them,
we gotta speak out and we got to speak up
and you're doing it.
I mean, this is such an important
space to have, you know,
to be able to talk about all these things.
- You have been not shy about
vocalizing these things.
Why is it important to you?
And why do you think not as many people
are as vocal as you
are about this subject?
- Well, being vocal has its cost.
It has a cost like when I became
very politically conscious
and then politically on my
social, I lost half my followers.
- [Nick] Wow.
- And then I got a lot of hate tweets,
"Go back to your country,"
"Go back to Mexico,"
which I'm not Mexican, but
I'll gladly go back to Mexico.
Cause it's a great country.
Still like when I post
political stuff on Facebook,
they go, "John used to be so entertaining,
now you're a bore"
but you know, all this hate
stuff, which I ignore, you know.
I feel like if you've achieved
a certain amount of success,
it's your duty to give back.
You gotta give back.
You can't be an ostrich and
stick your head in the sand
and pretend it's not
happening, not existing.
I don't know, I'm just
too socially conscious
and I feel like I had a fight to get here
and I've earned the scars and the wounds.
And I wanna talk about how
I had to fight to get here.
If anybody had done what I
had done, they'd be so much
further.
I mean I got a producer,
I'm not gonna name his name.
But he said, you know, "Too
bad John you're Puerto Rican,
'cause you're so talented.
Otherwise you'd be so much further along."
And that wasn't an insult,
it was an actual fact.
At the time I didn't know how to take it,
but now I know it's like, yeah,
because you were Latin,
you only gonna get so far.
You're only gonna get certain roles.
You're only gonna get
certain opportunities.
I was in a movie for a week
and then I get a call
from the director going,
"Oh John, I'm sorry,
I can't have you in the movie anymore."
I go, why?
What happened?
You lose the funding?
"No, no, we cast this Latin actress
and we can't have two
Latin people in the movie
because it becomes a Latin movie.
You know what I mean right?"
And I'm like, you mean...
And I'm like, I wanted to say like,
what do you mean it's better?
No, no he meant like I can
only have one token at a time-
- And this recent?
- No, this was about eight years ago.
I mean, tokenism is real,
glass ceilings are real,
colorblind casting was promised to me
by all the artists in the 70s,
we were gonna break that down
and then it wasn't until Hamilton,
2000 somewhat that they finally did it.
And it succeeded, it
showed that it does work.
- Take me to you going back to theater
for "Latin History For Morons."
I wanna talk about what I imagined
was probably a very personal conversation
between you and your son.
- Right.
- Can you take me to that day
when he comes home from school
and he tells you that he's being bullied?
Like what was that conversation like?
- That's kind of hard, especially
after having some mescal, I don't know.
I don't wanna get mad emotional on camera.
I don't wanna, I wanna keep this...
It's a hard conversation obviously.
You know, it's your beloved child
and they're being mistreated
and profiled racially
and ostracized and the school
didn't know how to handle it.
And it was terrible.
But I wanted to be an involved father,
I didn't wanna be like my dad,
who would we go, you know, go kick his,
don't come back home to kick his ass.
The door's locked to
you, 'til kick his ass.
I mean, I wanted to do that,
but I also wanted to be an evolved dad.
And I wanted to weaponize his information
and give him Latin
information about our history
to strengthen him, to arm him.
I looked through a history textbook
and it's like, wait a minute,
there's nothing mentioning
our contributions or anything.
It's like we didn't exist.
So I started doing mad
research and learning so much.
And the crazy thing was I
was the one that was healing.
I was the one that was being empowered.
And then I realized, oh my God,
I can do this for the 70
million Latinos in America.
I can do this maybe for
the 500 million speakers
in the world, through this work.
- Let me take it back
just a little bit to-
- You go wherever you wanna
go, this is your show.
- To the conversation-
- I'm not tryna hack up the airways bro.
- I know you don't
wanna get too emotional,
I just wanna talk a little
bit more on the personal side.
Cause it's like everyone
can turn on Netflix
and see the result of it.
- Right.
- But the fact that it came
from such personal caring,
from one generation to the
next generation of like,
I don't want you to go
through what I went through.
- No.
I don't want any kid to go
through what I went through.
I don't want any Latin kid to go through
what I went through.
I don't want any white
kid, black kid, Asian kid.
And for it to be so close
to home, it was devastating.
So I was definitely
couldn't believe that my son
is having to go through the
same shit 40 years later,
that I went through his crazy.
- So that conversation
happens at what point did,
does it instantly hit you?
- Oh my God he will not let it go.
(man laughs) Oh my God
he will not let it go.
You can tell he is Latin,
and Latin people are tenacious as (beep)
(man laughs)
Holy shit.
(people chattering)
(in Spanish)
I understand but we’re talking
about what I want to talk about.
We're gonna talk about
what I wanna talk about.
You can skirt the issue you want,
but I'm still getting back.
That is the reporter in his mom.
Let's talk about your mom.
(man laughs)
I wanna talk about your mom
because your mom's incredible,
she was a big influence on you.
No, no, don't try to skirt the issue.
- I'm gonna bring it back around.
I'm tied up with a nice knot.
You brought up my mom,
my mom's a professor in-
- In a good way, out of respect.
- In an amazing way.
My mom's a professor at Berkeley.
She comes in and stays with me,
it probably was for
Thanksgiving or Christmas.
I show her "Latin History For Morons."
She's like this is amazing.
(man laughs)
The next semester she
incorporates it into the class.
- Oh no get out its amazing.
- Yeah.
- That's incredible.
But your mom was a huge influence for you.
And-
- My mom's my hero.
Like I didn't turn on a TV to,
there wasn't anything on TV for me.
Like you said, there wasn't really much
for me to turn on and be
like, oh, this is something,
like my mom was my mom,
my dad, my best friend.
Like she wore all the hats.
- Yeah, the single Latin single mom.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
My mom was a single mom
telling me I had a dad until,
I mean, I still have a dad,
but he was at home until we were 13.
And then my mom became
a supermom, single mom,
Latin mom, dad.
- So you know.
- Yeah but we're the
same flavor, you know,
like sort of urban street intellectuals.
We're educated, we made it through college
because of our single moms and whatnot.
And it's a certain badge of honor.
- I wear that proudly.
- Yeah, yeah.
Me too, me too.
Here's to you.
- Here's to you
- Once again
(man laughs)
(calm music)
- What's left for you to accomplish?
- Oh, so much.
I love to help the next generation
get their work done, made,
produced.
There's so much great talent out there.
I wanna be able to help them.
I wanna be that studio exec
that gets their material
and their product greenlit.
- The exec we've been
needing for a long time.
I love it.
To you.
- No, no, you don't mean,
to you bro. (man laughs)
Here's to you again.
(man laughs)
- Let's stop this...
- No, no, no. You know,
you're a narcissist come on.
It's all about him.
Come on.
- This one is to you.
- No, no, you don't have
to do it. Don't even try.
(in Spanish)
To culture.
Let's go.
(in Spanish)
To culture.
- Much love, much love.
Much respect.
- Likewise.
(upbeat music)
So we're on the way back to the hotel.
As you can tell, we're in
a New York City street,
we got jackhammers, taxi cabs,
people walking by probably wondering
why I'm holding a camera, but yeah.
Taking a little time to reflect
on the conversation today.
I think the high school senior
in me is still freaking out
that I got to meet somebody
who inspired me greatly.
I am thankful for John
for opening up his home
and just being thoughtful
and sharing a very vulnerable side to him.
I think it's important you know,
we hear numbers thrown
around 70 million Latinos,
4% of movie roles.
But I think when you see
the humanity behind it,
when you see how it affects a son,
when you see how it affects a father,
I think that's when it's like,
okay, now I understand what
this conversation is about.
And I'm thankful for John for doing that.
And it's cold and I'm looking
forward to the next episode.
So thank you for tuning in
and we will see you at the next one.
(upbeat music)